hello and welcome to the new old review
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here to talk
about the guy
this guy the one with the hair that
looks amazing regardless of whether it's
up or it's down
his name is gojo and he is more or less
the crowning feature of jujutsu kaisen
however gojo
is a problem in fact the mere idea that
he even exists
at all is a problem one that is not at
all easy to solve and that has gone on
to damage
many lesser written series not just
anime or manga but media in general and
that would be the
concept of an overpowered protagonist
which i want to immediately distinguish
as a concept from the idea
of an overpowered antagonist which is
much more commonly seen particularly in
the realm of the shonen series
they tend to emerge from necessity more
than anything else you know the whole
idea that uh we need a new villain
someone who is more powerful than the
previous villain as well as all of our
protagonists combined and then
that sort of thing it happens it happens
a lot but the much rarer flip side of
this is the overpowered protagonist
someone who no antagonist could ever
hope to stand up to and who completely
dwarfs our other allied characters you
don't see this sort of thing too often
because
quite frankly they are narrative poison
to almost any series that is looking to
tell some sort of
engaging story with any form of tension
but one of the quotes i remember most
fondly from jujutsu kaisen is the idea
of using poison to fend off
other poison and that is what satorugojo
is he is
narrative poison that gege akutami has
deliberately injected into the world of
jude's kaisen in order to combat
other narrative poisons so how did
akutami achieve
what so so many have tried and failed
well let's go ahead and solve the gojo
problem a solution that begins with a
quick round of sato gojo or kat torigojo
a very simple mini game the rules of
which are as follows
there is a knock at your door knock
knock and you are going to answer it
however before doing so you must guess
whether your surprise
visitor is satoru gojo or katora gojo
should you guess incorrectly then your
punishment will be to subscribe to the
new world review resulting consistent
injections of jujutsukai send content
administered straight into your youtube
feed meanwhile if you do guess correctly
then
you will get to pat your visitor so what
will it be satoru
or kat torugojo make your choice now and
we shall reveal the answer in
three two one and bam it sautorogojo
unfortunately because i really did like
the cat but if you chose kataru then you
know the thing to do and please do say
hi in the comments below if you are a
newly cursed
denizen of the new world review welcome
but get back to the thing the thing that
is the actual topic of the video an
overpowered protagonist presents
a lot of hurdles to any author firstly
via the whole idea that tension
particularly in an action-based series
is almost entirely dependent on facing
off against adversity which
you know means encountering antagonists
who are superior in some sense be it
power
intelligence or maybe even both of those
things but having an overpowered
protagonist immediately renders that
potential null and void
because what's the big deal after all i
mean sure this villainous prick dude has
just shown up but
we have gojo you know so why should we
even bother worrying he'll take care of
it easy nor is there any tension to do
with that character themselves because
you know that they're going to be okay
in the end and before i continue just a
semantic point of order i know that some
people out there in the comments section
you
know who you are will probably take
issue with calling gojo a protagonist
because yuji is our primary protagonist
but i'm here to say that that p
word extends to most major characters as
well so don't go all internet
on me in the comments and begin a
sentence with actually
and seriously gojo is the legit center
of this world
every action taken in jutsu kaisen seems
to revolve around him in some way so he
is a protagonist foe
show in any case moving on because the
overpowered protagonists also tends to
have a bit of a negative effect on their
fellow protagonists very much minimizing
them sometimes to the point where you
even have to question why they're still
in the series at all a classic example
of this would of course be dragon ball
where protagonistic power got so
so out of control that there was just
really nothing for the extended cast to
do because they became more or less
pointless with a few key exceptions
and the basic solution to the first two
problems goes as follows
you need to remove the overpowered
protagonist from the story temporarily
because that's the only way that other
characters are going to have a reason to
kick into gear as well as the only way
to create any sort of drama and tension
through conflicts conflicts with
villains
and villains that would be absolutely
nothing if faced against our overpowered
dudebra but this solution actually leads
to another problem because sure it's
okay to do this a couple of times but
the longer the story goes on
the reasons for keeping the overpowered
protagonist out of the action become
more and more
desperate and contrived there's only so
many excuses an author can find and one
of my favorite things to note in shona
manga are all of the creative excuses
that mangaka
dig and dig and dig to find an implement
but if an author fails to deal with all
these problems satisfactorily then the
worst consequence pops up which is that
their overpowered character
is boring and that goes on to undermine
the entire series because they've taken
a big risk implementing such character
in the first place and now not only are
they a narrative detriment but their
presence also isn't anything special and
so the series enters a death spiral and
this sense of
boring-osity is particularly present if
the character is say
perfect in every aspect like not only
are they overpowered they're also the
smartest and most likeable in the series
if your character contains all three of
those features then congratulations
because you've just crafted the most
boring existence
in all of character history in fact i'd
honestly say that if your character has
even two out of three of those features
then your story is probably going to
struggle to deal with them which brings
us to gojo
because the first big tick of approval
he gets is by only possessing
one out of those three features he is
overpowered
and that is all he is certainly not the
smartest character introduced kaiser nor
is he the most likable and just quickly
actually i should point this out what i
mean by most likeable
is in world i don't mean the impression
that we have of gojo as fans because
he's obviously
wildly popular but within the world of
jude sky sen feelings regarding gojo can
range from mild discomfort to full
on hatred a range that comes from people
who are supposedly on our side as well
fighting the end of the curses and
everything for example gojo's
students they deeply respect him but
they also quite blatantly disrespect him
at the same time due to finding his
nature quite off-putting uttahime takes
us a step further by often wanting to
get legitimately mad at gojo
even if it is generally played for
comedy and if we want to something more
serious then well we would look
ganji who should theoretically be our
ally but clearly wants to rid the spot
of gojo as do the higher ups of the
entire jujutsu society even if he is
feared and respected for his power gojo
is not what i would call a well-liked
character in the series in fact the only
one who really represents how the
fanbase feels about him would be miwa
but she
is the outlier and this is such an
essential element to gojo's success
because if everyone in the series did
like him then jujitsukai sen would just
turn into a competition to see who could
jerk gojo off the hardest
metaphorically of course but i i don't
know actually maybe literally because
that does happen with these types of
characters in other media you know those
stories that are clearly just the
fantasies of the author writing
themselves as the overpowered
protagonist where all the guys are like
oh damn he's
cool and all the girls fall in love at
first sight like
i mean i don't want to name names so i'm
just going to pick three words from the
dictionary at random and it looks like
those words are
art online and sword but conflict at any
level is always
much more interesting and gojo has a ton
of that from almost
every character within his grand radius
and as for being the smartest look i
should have given gojo more credit here
because he is wildly intelligent however
a lot of that gets washed away through
his other personality traits a primary
one being arrogance gojo is a person who
has
well and truly gotten carried away with
his insane power so he doesn't
necessarily handle himself or situations
in the most
efficiently possible ways which opens up
rare moments of vulnerability and this
is very important because if gojo was
the greatest genius to have ever existed
in addition to being the most powerful
then there would never be a satisfying
reason to get the better of him so
gojo's arrogance and his
uh his aloofness is a detracting factor
for him in world but a huge
narrative advantage for akutami to wield
in addition to this his goofball nature
is also a great benefit because that
endears him all the more
to readers and watches i really cannot
imagine a world where gojo is stripped
of his comic aspects and the closest we
can really come to that is the original
jujutsu kaisen series where gojo had not
yet fully been realized he was a much
more serious stoic
presence and yeah he still had some gags
but the overall product was
significantly less captivating than the
character he went on to become
and another example of how beneficial
goofiness can be would be saitama
because one punch man handles him very
very well because like gojo saitama is
not well loved by society although i
guess he's more
ignored than anything and also he's a
bit of a [ __ ] which is very endearing
and even though he is this completely
overpowered protagonist that [ __ ] idiocy
often gives him the
the sort of illusion of maybe being the
underdog regardless like there is still
that bizarre moment of tension where
before every fight you're wondering
is this gonna be the one although i
wouldn't say gojo is quite the same in
that respect with a few
key manga related exceptions he is quite
clearly in command of his situations but
one feature that akitami really cannot
get around is the idea that for
anything dramatic introduce kaisen to
take place gojo
needs to be out of the picture and
there's only so many times you can get
away with the excuse of
gojo is out of town on another mission
or ho gojo he's off buying souvenirs
because he's crazy
what poor timing i guess it's up to our
first years to take on this special
great curse but thus far akhitami has
made this work quite well never has
there been a situation where i've sighed
and gone
ugh look this is clearly just an excuse
to keep gojo out and probably my
favorite gojo roadblock was during the
kyoto goodwill event where curtin was
constructed specifically to keep gojo
out
and nobody else you don't see that sort
of thing too often in other series and a
lot of credit here also goes to the
power system of jiu-jitsu
sen which allows for these strange
conditions to be set in exchange for
compromises elsewhere like to bring up
dragon ball again you are never going to
see a power based technique that is
designed to just stop
goku going for a war and admittedly a
great advantage that jujutsu kaisen has
is that it is a relatively young series
so the problem i pointed out earlier
regarding needing to find crazier and
crazier reasons to remove gojo hasn't
really had a chance to become apparent
yet if it will at all now i'm going to
throw up a quick spoiler warning for
anime only watches you
probably really don't want to listen to
what i'm about to say so please do skip
to this here time
thing to avoid spoilers but if you're a
margarita or if
you just don't care then shall we all
continue
i think the greatest praise i have for
how akhitami has handled gojo to this
point is having removed him from the
story
seemingly completely keeping him within
the prison realm is so important because
for the first time in all of
jiujitsukai-san it truly feels like we
have a desperate situation on our hands
even during shibuya i had the thought in
the back of my mind that gojo would
probably be released by the end so i
could not have been more pleasantly
surprised primarily because if he did
get released then girl we just have to
face the same problem of removing him
from the action for the next star and in
retrospect this entire first saga of
judith kaisen was pretty much
one gigantic endeavor just to get rid of
gojo everything came back to assist in
sealing him be it jojo's combat
experience the test curtain that was
thrown up during the goodwill event and
everything to do with ghetto not ghetto
and gojo's past it was all just one big
136
chapter endeavour to get rid of gojo so
with that in mind we really should keep
him sealed as long as possible to allow
everyone else to really stand on their
own feet and
take command of this series now speaking
of everyone else a very important aspect
as to why gojo works is that almost
every other character of jujitsu kaisen
is crafted to be compelling in their own
ways meaning that we do not have to rely
on gojo to carry the story because we're
also quite deeply invested in them as
well
which is important because it means you
don't always have the time or
inclination to ask awkward questions
like
where's gojo because you're just
completely in that moment with everyone
else
also here's the thing even when it comes
down to a very standard scenario of
overpowered gojo coming into conflict
with an antagonist whose defeat was
guaranteed it is still
so enjoyable to watch mostly because
skojo is a natural performer even in a
scenario where he's in the most
one-sided conflict imaginable he makes
that experience enjoyable and in the end
that's all that really matters because
the biggest problem with overpowered
characters isn't necessarily the
narrative headaches they can cause but
rather that they risk making the series
very flat
and unenjoyable after a certain point
the gojo is a master class of how to
avoid such stagnation firstly having an
overpowered protagonist is fine so long
as they aren't perfect
make them arrogant make them foolish
make them whatever just don't hand them
the keys to instantly becoming a god
secondly don't make them default
likeable by the other characters
insert those little character
personality conflicts because if this
overpowered character lacks excitement
in battle
then give them back some of that
excitement with how they relate to
others
and of course there's no getting around
this do not be lazy with how you choose
to implement their roadblocks you will
have to stop these characters from
taking action more often than not
actually so definitely get creative with
how that needs to happen
and what else can i really say gojo
definitely ticks all of these boxes this
character is simply a pure masterclass
but now that you've watched this video
go
and watch more videos more of my videos
ideally
because look there are things things
that you'll like like this video so i
look forward to seeing you there